mein name ist bei und ich freue mich
total dass ihr alle hier seid und hatten
noch wach sein also viele von euch
kennen mich wahrscheinlich gar nicht das
liegt daran dass ich zu den teils
youtube angehöre und werdet sicher und
den naturwissenschaften bitte ich
wünsche mir viele tatsächlich eigentlich
ganz cool
aber manchmal ist es auch so wie heute
zum beispiel bei sagten sie die machen
dieses mega fete youtube events am
wahlabend richtig geile live show haben
viele große youtuber am start vielleicht
kannst du als wissenschaftlerin ja was
zu umweltschutz und klimawandel sagen ja
klar dachte ich super themen klimawandel
und da kommt stimmung auf
das publikum toben sie bereit stage dive
vor
keine sorge wir wären ein bisschen über
umwelt reden aber damit ihr euch nicht
langweilt werde ich euch ja ein bisschen
mitnehmen auf einen kleinen psychotricks
ich habe nämlich als chemikerin
natürlich ein bisschen selbst gemacht
dass crystal meth dabei hierbei funk
grüßt im web gibt es dann in die kameras
aus sind
das wirkt zu ihr treffen hatte ich
eigentlich viel machen kleinen ausflug
in die psychologie das ist nämlich eine
ziemlich faszinierende wissenschaft und
zwar die psychologie weist immer wieder
ein wissenschaftlich nach dass die
menschen einfach saudumm sind so weil
man das ja auch feststellt immer mal bei
youtube konnte es sich also in der
kommission in der kommentarspalte macht
sich vor allem ein effekt der so
genannte dann in kuba effekt schon mal
was von gehört der daniel effekt
beschreibt die verzerrte wahrnehmung bei
ihnen kompetenten menschen die ihre
eigene kompetenz überschätzen
also kurz gesagt wenn leute einfach zu
dumm sind um zu merken dass sie dumm
sind zum beispiel deutschland schockiert
die welt ja tagtäglich mit seinem
rassismus sexismus und viele mehr aber
was nicht mit abstand am meisten
schockiert ist seine atemberaubende
inkompetenz
also der mann ist einfach so ohne
intelligent das ist eigentlich kein
wunder ist dass er mit wissenschaft
nicht viel anfangen kann
deswegen wäre ja auch die usa auf dem
pariser klimaabkommen raus haben die
ganze restliche da ist sich einig dass
wir co2 reduzieren müssen
selbst der partie also das oberhaupt der
katholischen kirche ruft alle menschen
dazu auf gemeinsam gegen den klimawandel
anzugehen
das heißt wir leben in einer zeit in der
wissenschaftler die katholische kirche
gleich überzeugen können als den
präsidenten der vereinigten staaten
wobei ob tunnel schon jetzt wirklich
alles was er so sagt auch meint das
können wir nicht wissen weil der mann
ist der größte heuchler
aber das sind wir alle menschen sind
häufiger wir haben klar das video
gesehen
die welt ist voll von doppelmoral und
psychologisch gesehen ist freilich zum
gaming kurve effekt wir haben hier einen
widerspruch zwischen dem wie ich mich
sehr und wie ich meine mitmenschen sehen
also bei was vorstand wird sich meinen
mitmenschen viel höhere standards auf
weil ich selber erfüllen kann also
beispiel ein politiker setzt sich
öffentlich für umweltschutz ein pferd
aber selbst mit seinem oder fliegt mit
seinen privaten und heuchler oder eine
instagram aventis überzeugte veganerin
liebt aber lederschuhe früchte es ist
ziemlich einfach andere dafür zu
verurteilen
aber ganz ehrlich entsprechend eure
handlungen auch wirklich ihren
überzeugungen immer also ich setze mich
zum beispiel dafür ein dass frauen nicht
nur viel aus denen sondern auch für ihr
gehirn respektiert werden und trotzdem
stieß jetzt gerade hier für euch mit
aufgeklebten wimpern und heute ist das
schlimmste was man so sein kann finden
wir das haben psychologen herausgefunden
und sie sind total fasziniert davon und
ich wäre jetzt mal kam mit euch die
sonne eine dieser psychologischen
studien nachstellen okay ich stelle euch
jetzt verschiedene fälle vor
und ihr könnt dann mal überlegen welcher
dieser fälle am schlimmsten ist klar
sagen wir hier wir vor einer der ersten
reihe der grad immerhin gespielt
[Gelächter]
kevin du hast jetzt kevin kevin hat fast
in den wald geschmissen
der plastik meldungen war geschmissen
und da hat man ihn danach fragt sagt er
habe ich nicht gemacht
voller saal b da haben wir klaus heißt
ob ich die klos oder klaus und auch
plastik nur in den wald geschmissen
dabei verkündet klaus regelmäßig und
öffentlich um geschützt bei das
allerwichtigste so was würdet ihr jetzt
schlimmer kevin den lügner oder klaus
dem heuchler die mehrheit der menschen
findet viel schlimmer als wir hatten
heuchler
wir verachten heuchler mehr als löwe ja
aber wenn man ganz ratzinger darüber
nachdenkt ist sich dabei eigentlich
völlig irrelevant
warum ja wir legen uns nicht deswegen so
sehr über heuchler auf weil sie
unmoralisch handeln ich werde mich nicht
über klaus auf bei der plastikmüll den
wald geschmissen hat ich lege mich nicht
der marken auch für den wald oder die
umwelt ich reg mich vor allem darüber
auf dass diese pizza sich besser
darstellt also eigentlich ist klaus oder
aber während ich mich hier so lange
breitung aufträge liga plastikmüll
umwelt und niemand interessiert und das
war plötzlich mir wirklich nur
interessiert das sehen wir an falls ii
hc
da haben wir hier ja jerome hat auf
lassen wenn sie den wald geschmissen und
als meine warum fragt sagt er ja habe
ich gemacht
ich stehe dazu ich hab's nicht so mit
der umwelt und wie finden wir ja ganz
okay oder ich meine wenigsten ist
ehrlich natürlich ist warum er sich aber
erneut ins dem wald doch scheißegal ob
jerome ehrlich ist oder nicht fakt ist
da liegt müll weil wir immer nur umfeld
denken finden wir den häusern am
schlimmsten
dann kommt der lügner und dann kommt der
ehrliche übeltäter aber wenn wir
wirklich an den wald denken würden
müssen jetzt genau andersrum sehen über
sein klaus das nervt dass du so ein
heuchler bist aber wie
nächstens macht sich klaus prinzipiell
für umweltschutz laut und kevin das
zweite und wohl dass du lügst aber
wenigstens scheint kevin zu wissen dass
etwas falsch gemacht hat
sonst würde ja nicht wie und warum hier
der eindruck auf und ehrlich zugibt auf
den wald zu schaffen
zudem müssten wir eigentlich sagen fahr
kino jerome also meiner meinung nach
sollten uns alle über zwei dinge einig
sein okay umweltschutz ist richtig wir
haben nur eine erde und versteht mich
nicht falsch wir brauchen umweltschutz
nicht für unsere arme mutter erde die er
bis viereinhalb milliarden jahre alt die
erdige den klimawandel schon überleben
sind jenige den klimawandel nicht
überleben werden in der geschichte der
erde ist die menschheit nichts wenn
alles schief läuft werden wir nichts
anderes sein als ein kurzer parasiten
befallen oder nur kurze krippe von der
sich die erde auch schon erholen wird in
paar millionen jahren dienst zum
beispiel haben die länge auf der erde
geht das wir und wo ist ihr ex heute im
hühnerstall also das huhn ist der
nächste genetische verwandte zum thema
zurzeit alles was vom blick übrig ist
ist ein huhn 1 nun eben genau was wir
von unseren lesern auch nicht viel wenn
wir so weitermachen wie bisher
deswegen wir brauchen umweltschutz nicht
für unseren planeten sondern wir
brauchen umweltschutz vor allem für uns
also erstens umweltschutzes wichtig
zweitens nachhaltig handeln ist halt
schwer und ein beweis dafür ist unsere
ganze rechnerei
wenn ich jetzt im herzen für fairtrade
bin aber trotzdem meine jeans weilheimer
kaufe weil es billig ist dann sagt mir
das vor allem eins nämlich das richtige
zu tun ist einfach nicht leicht weil uns
die disziplin fehlt die motivation fehlt
weil die egoisten sind marvin dohme sind
aber genau deswegen sind so sachen wie
das pariser klimaabkommen wichtig damit
wir uns gemeinsam und gehen um 30 zu
konkreten fortschritt zwingen
und ich will jetzt hier auch nicht
richter in schutz nehmen also versteht
es nicht falsch klaus aber
schöner sagen wir sind alle irgendwie
feuchter und dann hast doch wenigstens
keine kleinlichen weiters sei die sich
gegenseitig beschuldigen sondern last
gemeinsam unser bestes geben uns
gegenseitig dabei helfen
danke und jetzt freuen sich alle
[Applaus]